he you home affairs ministers of welcome
progress made in key areas to improve
the fight against illegal immigration
the minister's urged all stakeholders to
continue to actively implement
recommendations to combat the problem
made by the so-called taskforce
Mediterranean the task force was set up
last October after almost 300 migrants
died when their overcrowded boat sank
off the coast of lamb producer in Italy
the tragic events in Lampedusa are still
very much vivid in our minds and we need
to implement the actions identified to
further prevent loss of lives and build
up a credible migratory policy for the
future the aim is to boost cooperation
with countries that people leave and
transit to reach Europe improve legal
avenues for migrants to come to the EU
beef up the fight against trafficking
and organized crime strengthen border
surveillance and help member states
under high migration pressures The
ministers asked the European Commission
to provide a progress report in June
data protection was also discussed with
justice and Home Affairs ministers
briefed on proposals to protect people
with new rules on the processing of
personal information and on the
protection of privacy when that
information is transferred to countries
outside the EU the rules aim to provide
consistent and high level data
protection as well as to improve
cooperation and trust between the police
and justice authorities of different
member states